when we think of monsters and urban
legends there are quite a few that come
to mind from the Sasquatch in the
abominable snowman to El Chupacabra each
region has their own monster but they
claim to have seen today we travel to
the scottish highlands as we examine one
of the most notorious unsolved mysteries
The Legend of the Loch Ness monster as
its name would suggest the Loch Ness
monster is believed to inhabit a
freshwater Loch located in the Scottish
Highlands southwest of the city known as
Inverness hence the name Loch Ness the
Loch Ness monster is often described as
a prehistoric aquatic dinosaur like
creature unlike any animal we see today
the creature was often compared to the
species known as the Plesiosaurus do
resemble each other quite closely the
theory has been disproved multiple times
throughout the years the Plescia saw was
a cold-blooded reptile it would need a
warm tropical environment to survive one
that is not native to Scotland if we
couple this with the fact that Loch Ness
is around 10,000 years old dating back
to the end of the last ice age it's most
likely at the Loch was frozen over
making it quite easy for us to roll out
the Plescia saw as a possible
explanation
the first ever recorded sighting of the
monster was in 565 AD by an Irish monk
named Saint Columba Colombo and his
companions came across a group of local
residents who were bearing a man by the
river Ness when asked what had happened
they explained the man was swimming in
the river when he was attacked by a
beast in the water Colombo and his men
then traveled across the river and when
the creature approached them he made the
sign of a cross telling the creature to
go no further and go back at once
appearing to heed his warning the Beast
turned and fled Columba's men and the
local people could only thank the monk
for what they perceived as a miracle
over the years to come rumours did
indeed spread of the strange events that
took place that day and there are even
stories of locals believe in that Loch
Ness was home to mythical creatures such
as kelpies shape-shifting water spirits
that were known to take the form of a
horse this did contribute to the notion
that in the depths of Loch Ness lived a
creature a creature that quickly became
a favorite of the locals and earned the
nickname Nessie despite its first
sightings been almost 1,500 years ago it
wasn't until alleged photos of the
creature began to surface that people
began to question whether the Loch Ness
monster was more than just a legend in
1934 the first photograph of the
creatures neck and head was published in
the Daily Mail newspaper the photo
itself was believed to have been taken
by Robert Kenneth Wilson a gynecologist
from London at the time Wilson refused
to have his name associated with the
picture which led to it being known as
the surgeons photograph Wilson claimed
that he was enjoying the view of the
Loch when he saw the monster he grabbed
his camera and began to take photos he
took numerous photos but the majority
were discarded because of how grainy and
unclear they were the image that was
eventually used shows what appears to be
the head and neck of the creature just
above water for those who believed in
the legend the photo was considered
evidence of the monsters existence and
for those who were a little bit more
skeptical the creature in the photo was
dismissed as driftwood or a small animal
similar to a bird or an otter by the
early 90s it was mostly agreed that the
photo was part of an elaborate hoax
in 1999 a book by the name of Nessie the
surgeons photograph exposed was
and as its title suggested the book
featured details regarding the original
photo the creature in the photo was
actually a toy submarine built by
Christian Spurling the son-in-law of
Marmaduke Wetherell weathera was
employed at the time by the newspaper
that published a photo the Daily Mail
where the row had previously had an
article written on footprints that he
had found and believed to have belonged
to the Loch Ness monster a cost of the
footprints was made and they were sent
to local scientists to examine the
footprints had turned out to be nothing
more than someone playing a prank
and as a result Wetherell was ridiculed
by his employer and the public to get
revenge
whether on a number of others hatched a
plan that would involve building the
Loch Ness monster of their own the model
was built from a toy submarine with its
head and neck being made from wood putty
after a short period of testing in a
local pond the model was placed in the
Loch Ness where the photos were taken
they were then handed to Robert Kenneth
Wilson who sold them to the Daily Mail
who then announced the monster had
finally been photographed so I guess you
could say that whether one ko had the
final laugh constructing what is
considered to be one of the biggest
hoaxes in the history of the Loch Ness
monster and convinced in a national
newspaper to publish their story
following the events of 1934 the number
of people claiming to have seen this he
greatly increased with a host of fake
sightings and hoaxes some of them appear
to be no more than practical jokes and
other people may have seen the Loch Ness
monster as an opportunity to make some
money selling their stories to local
newspapers and anyone who would believe
them the interest in Nessie Peaks so
much that a circus owner by the name of
Bertram Mills offered a 20,000 pound
reward equivalent to around two million
pounds today to anyone who could capture
the beast for his circus but no one was
able to ever claim their reward just as
the number of sightings continue to be
reported there have been a number of
studies done using sonar to examine Loch
Ness for any unusual activity there have
been several objects detected but due to
how murky the water of Loch Ness is
cameras have been unable to capture any
definitive images resulting in any
findings being dismissed as rocks air
bubbles and schools of fish in 2014 and
15 there were attempts to map Loch Ness
using Google Street View and Apple maps
but similar to all the other studies
done any images found were debunked as
ripples caused by boats or driftwood
there were a host of TV shows and
documentaries that attempted to solve
the mystery of the Loch Ness monster
but once again without any definitive
evidence it appears the mystery will
continue to go unsolved it appears that
the true winners of this situation are
the people of Inverness themselves the
legend of the Loch Ness monster appears
to have helped put their small town on
the map with tourists from all around
the world flocking to Inverness to see
if the legend is true and possibly get a
glance of Nessie whether you believe in
the legend of the Loch Ness monster or
not the alleged sightings of Nessie
continue even to this day and the
mystery of what lies in the depths of
the Loch Ness remains unsolved
I'd like to thank all the patrons who
have pledged and supported me this month
this video was indeed their choice if
you guys are interested in becoming a
patron and further supporting the
channel and having a say in future
videos then the links will be in the
description below but as always I've
been your host mythology in fiction
explained